some of the biggest names in music and
entertainment are coming together for an
historic festival that will be broadcast
across the globe it's called one world
together at home it's being curated by
Lady gaga and is being organised by the
World Health Organization and the
advocacy group we all know them global
citizen only on CBS this morning cisco
CEO that's chuck Robbins reveals how his
company is answering the call for
coronavirus help our relationship with
global citizens started and roughly two
years ago and we've had a phenomenal
partnership since then and when this
crisis began we we began working with
them also on how we could respond
globally we made an initial two million
dollar contribution to the world health
organization and as part of one world
together at home we're making another
five million dollar donation to the
World Health Organization we worry a
great deal about those people in
countries around the world whose health
care systems can't support a massive
outbreak and we need to get ahead of it
and we also need to celebrate and help
those frontline health care workers who
are out there fighting the fight every
day by getting them the appropriate PPE
that they need so that they can actually
take care of those who are suffering
with this virus take care of them and
not feel at risk themselves a lot of
people using chucks company lately have
you noticed on the screens you'll see
that cisco webex that's the company he
runs Thank You Chuck Robbins one world
together at home we'll celebrate
healthcare workers and those on the
front lines of this crisis only on CBS
this morning we spoke to act - let's try
there again only on CBS this morning we
spoke to actress and philanthropist
Priyanka Chopra Jonas yesterday about
her role in this huge event this show is
something completely different from what
global citizen ever done because this is
not a fundraiser this is not us asking
you when you're watching the two hour
concert while all of us are sitting at
home to donate money the idea is to get
the private sector to make donations for
for corporations to help governments and
the marginalized in the world and take
care of them who don't have the ability
to live in homes itself
don't have the ability to have the
privilege of being hot how do we do that
if we're not raising money how do we do
that well what global citizen does is
basically use citizens to implore to
governments to implore the companies
send out emails so millions and millions
of people are asking people to take
action and that's how we're raising the
money the citizens can then put pressure
on the corporations that's what they can
use your individuality use your voice
because each one of us have it to put
pressure on governments on on the
private sector to say you need to do
your bit in this I say Priyanka this
this coronavirus Cove in nineteen it
truly is a moving target and there seems
to be new information coming in at all
times mm-hmm take nothing for granted I
think it's really really important for
us sitting at home to not panic because
there's obviously going to be a sense of
fear the w-h-o is the right source get
your information from them the CDC of
global citizen people that you know will
give you correct information instead of
you know feeling stir-crazy and panicked
at home with all the forwards that we
keep getting on social media etc how are
you dealing with it how are you a NIC
together as a couple
processing this and getting through this
I think we recognize our ability to have
the privilege of being able to stay in
self isolation we've been spending a lot
of time with each other reaching out to
family friends making sure we're aware
of what's happening in the world making
our contributions donations so that we
feel like we're actually doing something
and even though we're all sitting at
home our hands are not tied we can do so
much you said something that I think is
very interesting Priyanka we're still in
the early stages two weeks three weeks
you said it's actually a privilege to be
able to stay home what do you mean by
that a lot of us don't think about this
but the one thing that at least in our
home I think about a lot and it helps me
from being that person who's like I'm
bored and I you know I don't have
anything to do I think about the fact
that I have a home I have the ability to
eat I have the ability to talk to my
family and friends and they're safe out
there and I am feel that that is a
privilege and
need to recognize that individually as
well and kind of help the world get
through this together even in America
not just in low-income countries around
the world I mean this this disease is
such a leveler of sorts it doesn't
matter who you are how much money you
have where you come from what your race
is things that divided the world in such
a big way
all of this time this disease can get to
anyone we all know that this is a global
pandemic and I think about people in
this country how do you get people in
this country to think of others when
they're trying to survive themselves I
think having lived in India where you
know survival is what you think of
before luxury for a lot of people in the
world I mean for a lot of people in
India I think it's very important for us
to understand that yes we are going
through what we're going through and you
know worrying about how we're gonna get
out of it in America but I think you
have to understand our position in the
world because this is affecting
everybody in the same way do you think
the world will come back to normal do
you believe that I think it'll be a new
normal
no one who can define what that will be
but I think it'll it'll make the world
curious and thoughtful and think about
hygiene and how important that is
I think it'll also be scary after two
months maybe to come out for the first
time meet people that's gonna take a
little while for the world to come back
to normal and I don't think normal will
ever be the same
you know what Priyanka I've been saying
it's an equal-opportunity heartbreaker
that's how I feel about it yeah it's
such a it's such a tragic thing to see
like which is why I like I feel like
what global citizen is doing with this
show is such an incredible thing your
exact role on the 18th will be what
exactly what are you planning to do
obviously I'm not a musician I can't be
contributing like that but my idea will
be to talk about the private sector
contributions that will come in I got a
suggestion for you I know you don't
necessarily sing but your husband
certainly does why don't the two of you
do a duet see kind of thing I just okay
okay but really good in the shower
really really good does that mean maybe
you two could do it do it maybe I'm not
gonna pull him
to the segment for sure that's happening
alright okay don't tell them though we
won't tell them you know something
interesting guys so it'll be on all
three networks Stephen Colbert Jimmy
Kimmel and Jimmy Fallon are all hosting
together I think that is a cool thing
that hasn't been done before to see the
three of them I like that yeah I love it
I love what she said about appreciating
her home yeah I thought that do I know
Anthony I hadn't thought of it that way
it's in different way of looking at it
and I like what she said - you're
sitting at home but it doesn't mean your
hands are tied I like that thank you
very much Priyanka you can watch one
world together at home next Saturday
April 18th at 8 o'clock Eastern 5
Pacific right here on CBS and all Viacom
CBS networks